i'm going to interrupt you because i
want to ask about celebration
of course was a big week i have to ask
you about the conversation you had
with president-elect joe biden that
energy you had to make that phone call
and say congratulations what was it like
for you
well listen i think it's really
important that we always
uh make sure we have a good relationship
with the united states that's certainly
something that i've
worked on very hard over the past past
few years
in sometimes challenging situations but
you know joe
uh will be my third american president
uh and uh
they're never easy because the the
issues are are so important but
obviously
on on a lot of issues we connect whether
it's on climate change whether it's on
uh working together on the world stage
and i think there's a there's going to
be a lot of good things we're going to
be able to do in the coming years
yeah and i'm so excited because i think
a lot of people who are here are
just over the moon at the idea of kamala
devi harris
the first female who is indian and black
descent is is a moment for my girls it's
a moment for me
and to celebrate something like that
that's what makes diwali also special
because it is a new beginning
no it's it's very very exciting and and
the impact on
uh young girls uh across uh across
the united states but across the world
around the world really to see
that there's nothing they can't aspire
to i mean we know
we've done a lot of work on on women's
equality
uh but there are remain barriers for uh
women who are racialized for women
facing various
intersectional identities and really
highlighting that
that there is uh a path and there are
role models that
uh people can uh can draw on and uh you
know she's uh
she's very very impressive we're gonna
have a very uh strong and
and fierce team uh in all the right ways
in in that white house
i'm taking over the interview i'll turn
it back to you now
no no listen uh we're both uh we're both
excited about uh
about the opportunity to celebrate uh uh
you know as
as you as you think about your girls and
and looking at kamala and
looking at just how the world is coming
what do you what do you see as the
opportunities for them because you've
broken down some uh
serious barriers in in in your life and
hopefully you're
make i know you're making it easier for
your girls but for a lot more than that
what do you tell them as they as they
grow up you know
it's a really good question i think one
of the things that we kind of reflected
about
the last few months is to kind of pause
and find what your voice is what is your
truth what do you want to do with that
voice and
over the last few years being a mother
to two girls i don't want them to deal
with the hurdles i did as a minority
i want them to know it's okay to be who
you are
it's okay to celebrate it's okay to do
that in canada
and so going forward i just want them to
learn the idea of confidence and
knowing they could do whatever they want
so it's a big task
and this generation is so unique
compared to our generation
and you know as a father it's what you
can't tell your kid just do this or this
they want to do tick-tock they want to
do
you know what is it that they want so uh
you know
for me that's really important it's just
finding that voice and making sure my
girls hear it as well
well uh sangeeta you're really lucky to
have
two daughters i i only have one but i
have two sons on top of that
and uh one of the most important
messages i have for my daughter is of
course
she can do anything uh but one of the
most important messages i have for my
sons
is that their sister can do anything as
well
and my sons have got to be uh feminists
as well as my daughter
uh and and that that message of how we
move forward
and embrace diversity although i have to
say just
just the difference from our generation
to uh
to theirs they get it they feel it in
their bones that no no no
you know these barriers just make no
sense and i am inspired by
by them and by by their friends as as we
think about the world we're building
together
now i need to know what's your favorite
because diwali is all about sweets and
dessert what is your favorite dessert
oh no see this is the the question i've
been dreading because
uh the people who know me know i'm not
much of a dessert guy
uh and uh and uh you know diwali is all
about the uh
the mitas and the sweets uh
and i've i've had many of them at
wonderful festivals
and i look forward to uh getting back to
them but i've i've never managed to even
finish a
a single whole treat uh i i do it out of
politeness
uh i'll uh i'll wait for the main course
uh every time
how are you doing through all of this
coping with the covet and being with the
family
there's a silver lining being home with
the kids in the family but how are you
coping with an
end have you learned something about
yourself that's unique that you didn't
know about
yourself before um i think i think we're
all learning an awful lot about the
things we used to take for granted
and the things that we missed out on and
i will admit that over the past number
of years
uh you know as i was you know always off
at work and then traveling and doing all
sorts of things
um covet has really forced us to connect
a lot more with family
and uh the attention i've been able to
give to the kids
uh as we've been locked in together as
we've been
home a lot more as i'm never traveling
now except by zoom
um you know that has uh brought
something that i think
uh we're all gonna get gonna hang on to
so uh even as
even as this this time is difficult for
all of us and
so many families have faced uh have
faced real tragedies
uh and are you know powering through
some dark days
there are some things where we remember
the ability to lean on each other and be
there for the people who are most
important to us
that that really really matter so you
know i i i can't help but think that
you know many years from now and decades
from now even
our our kids are going to look back on
this time of uh the covid crisis
that when they were kids and they'll be
telling their kids about it and there
will be
there will be beautiful stories uh about
remembering what was really important
alongside the heartbreak that so many
families are facing yeah and divali's
also about
joy so what what brings you joy
well that's that's that's the kids uh
that's the time we spend together i mean
there's uh
so many things we can't do because of
this but uh
getting out for uh for a bike ride or a
walk in the woods uh
uh those are things that we've uh we've
really uh really taken the time to do
and it's those simple connections and
that's the simple
uh love of family that uh that has to uh
bring us the most joy and fulfill us the
most
uh you know i i miss seeing my friends i
think we all do
and uh you know the idea of of uh you
know chilling with uh
uh with friends uh is something we're
all looking forward to but i think we
all know
we're gonna have to hang in there for a
number of more months
and uh and so you know satisfy ourselves
with zoom
uh as uh as we come together virtually
for important moments like this one
because we know if we do
right for the coming months we will get
through this
and things will get better and we'll
we'll have a lot of things we no longer
take for granted
you know there's a lot of frontline
workers and small business owners who
are tuned in right now
and of course i want to say from the
bottom of my heart
is thank you for what you're doing but
what is your message to them
about going forward and really just
thanking them
well i think i think the message is and
divali's about that but canada is about
that as well which is
being there for each other leaning on
each other i mean
we made a very simple promise as a
government at the beginning of this
pandemic
that we'd be there for people that we'd
have your back and we will be there
no matter what uh regardless of how long
this takes regardless of what it takes
we will be there to support canadians to
support their families to support small
businesses
to support workers who lose their jobs
to support our front line workers
you know canada has a really good fiscal
position going into this
uh this which means we can actually be
there to support each other not every
country can do that
uh we are lucky uh it's still tough and
it's going to be tough and we're all
facing challenges but we'll make it
through this because we'll be there for
each other and we'll come out
even stronger than before that's my my
commitment to canadians and
and it's something that we've
demonstrated every step of the way and
we'll continue to so
despite the anxiety despite the the very
real challenges we're facing
often around stress and uh mental health
and
real health like physical health and
being there for each other um
know that it will get better uh it's
gonna be a tough winter
uh but the spring will be much better
and and the summer will be better
we just have to hang in there be there
for each other
while we stay distanced and did you buy
your wife a gift for diwali
i i buy my wife uh plenty of gifts uh uh
for various occasions but uh uh i i
think i missed this one uh i i will have
to uh
i will have to try and make up i think
we have lots of halloween candy left
over that maybe uh maybe i can uh
halloween with her on that one oh come
on you can do better than that
yeah well it's sort of hard to pop down
to the corner store these days
i know it is it is so wonderful to chat
with you and again happy diwali to
everyone and i'm truly honored to be
here with you and
um i know you you celebrate every
culture and it means a lot to us that
you do that
uh and uh for us to do this right now um
do you
will you be dancing anytime soon
and some indian music uh i uh i look
forward to continuing to celebrate
virtually with everyone
that's really one of the great things
about about canada
is uh uh we all celebrate each other's
uh celebrations as a way of bringing us
together
uh and uh i look forward to some some
wonderful
uh performances this diwali but uh i
won't be participating myself
thank you everyone it's wonderful seeing
you thank you thank you for being part
of this sangeeta you have a great night
and happy diwali